كيفما خصل المشترك به المحتمل في
التحقيقات وزاره العدل المستمره في
الافصاح غير المخول به الوثائق
لان هذه تحقيقات اجراميه مستمره فيجب ان
يحيل لكم الى وزاره العدل اسئله
هي مساله خاصه بجهات انفاذ القانون ومن
غير مناسب لي او اي مسؤول وزاره الدفاع
التعليق في هذه اللحظات خاصه
وبعد ان نحصل على معلومات وزاره العدد سوف
نحيطكم بها كما اشار وزير استون بان وزاره
العدل هي التي تاخذ هذه المساله الجديه
ونستمر بالعمل على مدار الساعه على جانب
الوكاله الداخليه والمجتمع
استخباراتي لفهمي عمقي واثري هذه
التسريبات ونحن قائدنا بما نستطيع ان نقول
فيما يخص التحقيقات وزاره العدل المستمر
ونحن ايضا محددون بما استطع ان اقوله هو
حول اي من الوثائق نفسها ونحن نتفهم
واهتمام الاعلام الاسئله حول محتوى هذه
الوثائق ولكننا ودون نشير ان هذه سياسه
مستمره لان المعلومات السريه اذا
طرحت عبر الانترنت فهذا لا يعني بانها
تغير السريه
بتصنيفها الذين يغطون وزاره اول طويله
يعرفون المناقشين معلومات سريه نظرا
لاثرها المحتمل على الامن القومي وكذلك
امن وسلامه افرادنا ومن حلفائنا وشركائنا
ولا هذه الاسباب سوف نستمر بتشييعها منكم
الذين يقدموا الاخبار هذه القصه ان ياخذ
هذه العوامل بنظر الاعتبار
واخذ نظر باعتبار اثري هذه المعلومات
الحساسه والمعلومات وعدم طرحها عبر
الانترنت كما ان الوزير
استضعف وزير الدفاع في الكانتاغان وناقشه
قوه علاقات الدفاع بين امريكا
كما ناقش والمصالح الامنيه المشتركه في
اوروبا من ضمنها ووضع
للردع في ظنيس او المجموعه
القادمه الوزير اسنسي سافره للسويد للقاء
نظيره لمناقشه المسائل ذات مسائل خاصه
بالمسائل الدفاعيه وسيسافر من هناك الى
المانيا هو وجنرال يستضيف يعني اجتماعا في
الحادي وعشرين من ابريل في مجموعه اتصال
الخاصه باوكرانيا وهذا هو الاجتماع الحادي
عشر لهذه المجموعه منذ تاسيسها من قبل
وزير استون قبل عام من الان
لمتابعه المزيد من والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات